I gotta tell you because this is the
third year right I feel like I've become
kind of a comic-con expert I really do
I do I really do yeah absolutely you
know when it comes to comic books
superhero movies
sci-fi fantasy all things comic-con I'm
gonna say this is maybe a little
controversial but I'm gonna say there
was literally no bigger expert than this
guy right here I believe that you should
have no problem passing the just
invented Comic Con citizenship test
all right sit down let's fire these up
all right here we go these are some
tough questions all right here we go
here we go what is Darth Vader's
original name Anakin Skywalker easy
Harry Potter come on like you cheer for
that one yeah Harry Potter's Patronus
takes the form of what animal a stag
easy
what were umple Ben's dying words to
Peter Parker
beware the reboot white Walker is
another name for a Trump cabinet member
what what superhero smells too strongly
of Cologne uberman uberman green arrow
sometimes goes by the name right on red
arrow okay yeah what did George Lucas
originally want to call lightsabers
laser dongs
who is ant-man's
arch enemy uncle woman
really that was a slow burner I saw them
I saw it percolating in the crowd people
were like oh yeah don't worry I guess
they have that legal marijuana down here
too he who controls the spice control
Chipotle what's the one thing a
transformer can't turn into a good movie
Coenen how is spider-man in bed amazing
what about the whole incredible the
x-men uncanny the flash fast
Aquaman wet the Fantastic Four
okay only okay the first time pretty
lame the second time absolutely awful
the third time all right time for the
visual round visual round I'm gonna show
you two or more characters from comic
books and movies and you have to tell me
what the mashup of those characters
would be called can I can do this okay
there we go let's put it up Aquaman plus
Wolverine the mash-up is sushi deluxe
yeah Aquaman plus flash flush that would
be flush yeah
kitty pryde Plus Deadpool that would be
kiddy pool cue from Star Trek The Next
Generation plus mr. Mitchell flick from
DC Comics that would be this town in
Yugoslavia all right Doctor Who plus
Doctor Strange plus Doctor Doom yes the
mash-up is my network of approved
primary care physician
dr. dr. strange is a really good
urologist yeah
all right and finally got the final one
here Red Hulk + gray Hulk that's easy
Steve Bannon
[Applause]
you